après ça dépend aussi si on avait
quelqu'un d' exposer ou pas je suis avec
quelqu'un qui fait un métier qui n'a pas
forcément envie lui d'être exposé jean
mich
bah moi je suis solide donc les bars on
s'est dit c'est quoi que je tenais à
vous le temps que le magazine sorte je
suis déjà plus avec donc sept mois ça me
gênerait pas ça me gêne pas de
m'afficher bâtiment heureux d'afficher
son bonheur vient pas là mais vous dites
oui quel est l'événement depuis tout à
l'heure je sais pas pourquoi pas oui
mais vous avez dit ferme ta gueule d'un
prêt du tout maintenant quand on a un
truc non mais je trouve ces mois-ci il
ya une certaine hypocrisie
je ne crois pas une seule seconde nabila
qui se dit je me suis posé des questions
très bon enfant par femme à 2 secondes
elle savait très bien qu'elle pose texte
allait faire le buzz à les nourrir tout
son business ne critique pas c'est la
société qui veut ça mais moi je suis pas
du tout dans la bande la placement de
produit j'en fais pas mais en revanche
je pose pas grand chose parce que j'ai
pas grand chose à poster mais si j'avais
ici j'étais heureux avec une femme ça ne
vient pas de montrer primés et donc vous
devez donc je trouve qu'ils ont mathieu
secret dit pas ça les stars de terre et
est aujourd'hui la grande marcel des
marseillais les ch'tis tout ça gagnent
entre cinquante et cent cinquante mille
euros par mois avec leur énorme
jusque là pas de problème le problème
c'est que tout est si j'avais aussi à w9
un petit peu tout maintenant des enfants
et vous regarder leurs enfants parfois
même avant de naître ont déjà un compte
instagram et oui il ya des bébés vous
voyez le bébé quand vous cliquez sur
bébé il ya toutes les marques mix à ta
ta ta ta ta ta le baiser le bébé a lui
même va apporter 30 à 40000 euros par
mois ce qui me choque c'est qu'on ne
donne pas au choix déjà ne donne pas le
choix ce bébé de devenir connus ou pas
et comme disait un psy on ne sort jamais
indemne de la célébrité
ces mômes n'ont déjà pas le choix est on
en train de faire une génération mais de
futurs jordi et ça va être un drive